bella tutti ragazzi noi siamo i pali j
oggi siamo su questo che stringe questa
intro ovunque noi siamo su tablet oggi
da un test è un gioco della epic games
che potete scaricare magari utilizzando
anche il codice creatore che vi lascio
in descrizione che vi lascio qui perché
c'è l editing dell'incredibile e vi
lascio alla descrizione il gioco da
scaricare perché dovete assolutamente
provarlo o giro giochiamo con pietra
dove sei uomo delle caverne vieni qua
fatti mostrati a me dove stare lì ma
l'uomo con l'ascia giusta e sono tipo
quad al mercato quale mercante amiche
sono aspetta aspetta che c'è carlo
sotero pasto io lo voglio in gruppo
quest'uomo non hai capito allora negozio
guarin stefano battaglia
sostieni un creatore nome creatore free
ragazzi lo deve fare tutti noi viola che
deve la tastiera deve esplodere vi per
quanto lo fate quindi fai gtv supportato
un creatore per cortesia licenza di
battaglia non è per battaglia si chiama
pass battaglia come lo chiamiamo perché
informa che in realtà quasi diamo al
passante si chiama licenza di caccia
liquidity day ciò che ci permette di
cacciare è un po l'equivalente appunto
il buzz battaglia di fort nike che
prenderei adesso posso prenderlo perchè
quello che vi premio che fai te ne privi
aggiorna lite attenzione ma è davvero
questa licenza di caccia parte si sono
diventate un calciatore fortissimo
ottieni di compensi aspetto che ciò
lericom penso ad altro nell'ombra tempo
nell'ombra passo dell'ombra amante
nell'ombra
siccome la mia lancia è veramente [ __ ]
se permettete ragazzi però posso anche
comprarvi quella nello studio shop oggi
ragazzi acquista supportarci amico il
codice famiglie tv grazie ci sono amico
sei pronto mi sono finalmente pim pato
tutto con le cose che ho è che va beh
niente niamo abbiamo la stessa entrata
ma toglierti a sembri un divo di
hollywood
mi piace sei molto carino ora arriva la
parte più difficile del gioco ovvero
davvero combattere e vero c'è il carlo
a volte si nascondono il bravo io lo
dico io ma perché al buio che sfiga la
prima al buio
si cerca chi lo trova per primo vincere
milioni iscritti al e ho provato chi lo
trova per ii che ci mischiamo fatta una
vederle giganti guerra che sbatte via
gli alberi questa cosa ascolta esposto
di sbattere via gli alberi lo
attacchiamo vado vado ai vada vada
annunci incisiva la prima secondo me
moriamo tantissimo però vado
siamo come non so se 88 è l'hack è male
mi piace perché tutto al cobà linoso
carino e vero evento codice hamas che
fetta ammazzo oggi non ha niente insomma
non è vero non sono caduto ancora strano
eh ma non fai neanche in tempo a fuggire
quando si illumina sei morto
praticamente è proprio piegarsi la vita
fa schifo
poi la prima volta che lo fai lo alla
rete ogni volta che voglio scappare
prima perché io capisco che mi sta
colpendo griderò scappa e tu mi vedrai
colpito fortissimo perché non lo stato
era capito prima non riuscirò a far ciò
che dico a riquadri coni coppette che
carico ciao
stavo scherzando 6.1 barroso sentono
corriere svelò diverse intrappolare
mentre un casino
dentro sei tu e il boss il fantastico
gioco con roche laterano gliela
dhurandhar di queste tranquillo io non
li ho visto il tour presentato mai sulla
gamba sinistra amico ma sinistra mi
chiamo turno mia o del boss dei boss
no la mia non ha detto che questa il
corner rotto
no il corno torna la spada martian sei
pazzo è in avaria stessi si sono fatte
sulla faccia oppure
e morto eh sì ma cavolo è durato meno
dove non è previsto otto minuti il mio
rango e di quello del gruppo sv vabbè
c'è un coso nucleo 6 epico da aprire le
dighe leggendario cela rinforzata p3
ho trovato epico soleggiamento spiegano
intralciarla rinforzata ecco lamenta la
salute massima buono amico mi giudicano
grosso ma dove non lo so però lo
cerchiamo non è un cane lo immaginavo
fosse un cane non è un cane a rito se
cerchi un cane già porti svantaggiato
loro non è un cargo era un drago non è
un drive sono mercato non lo so io
separando
eccolo qua arriva al rimarrei rosso è un
gufo enorme e un gufo grosso più grosso
male gli ho fatto niente ai ragazzi ma
che male mi ha fatto malissimo però
vabbè non fa niente se per caso mi si
riattiva la roba di prima tutte meno una
maniera che non puoi capire uno dei vini
qua orca vacca scherzavo secoli manuale
che botta nel deretano questa l'ho
sentita forte come faceva fare con la
roma letta da ta ta ta ta ta ta ta ta ta
ba apposta ma gunnes ho ucciso io valeva
e vale ancora che forte del porto di
porto e non riesco più ad attivare
quella maremmana
allo schifo basso dirmi mara e basta
tirarmi varate questo implica pugni di
qualcosa smetti ai piana pulini amico
ray ha visto o totalmente il rovente che
si è cagato dopo è morto è morto
incredibile secondo questa volta ha
fatto bene per il meglio del solito
prevedere c rispetto agli altri e molto
mentre voglio provare a vedere se disco
aumentare i livelli lo sceglie la
dell'arma intende europee a cosa
vogliamo fare ora torniamo su quello di
auschwitz nutra li possiamo fare non ho
sbagliato io aumentato ma sbagliato io
se vuoi o un'ora farti molto molto molto
divertente bene ho accarezzato un cane è
già aver grazie vela fitcher migliore di
dante poi accarezzare i cani forza forza
non c'è tempo da perdere per far fuori
il boss ma io volevo accarezza di cani
ma scusami
io l'ho trovato ma cosa creature
detector
dov'è che sei lancio il florean era
l'era veloce che sia incazzato con
questo tipo in ad ora fa bene orari my
friends
ma se sei lontano eccoti significa che
fai tipo l'avenger ii papa mi papa sara
grossissima si è un po la finestra amico
la finestra
le zanzare non sarebbe una volta mi sono
nella mia secondo me quando serve niente
devi morire basta se io mi trovo una
roba del genere in casa ma mi ammazzo da
solo faccio così guarda a cui mi scusi
mi scusi guardi
casa mia è sua perché senza limitando
per favorita ma c'è perché sono un ragno
no no non c'è da meno male mammamia
beretta con la morte
mena yemen agli ami come l'aiea
sparandolo sparando ho messo le pizze
dell'auto hanno messo io ce l'hai un out
and per farlo fuori o ciò che è male
porca vacca porca ha mai atterrato
perché possa essere centrato vaira vice
pato lo spaccato di botte finalmente il
momento che aspettavo acquistarli un
modo o no ma con atti si ritirato
successore io l'ho fatto io non ho mai
io ne ho fatto un anno fa mi sono tirato
visto quanto accaduto scusami di aiuto
ha fatto della storia se abbiamo fatto è
perché siamo bene va bene ok ha fatto
ridere che eri morto e tavano fatto solo
io invece di si gira ter in piedi quindi
ho fatto io comunque essi nobel hanno
fatto fino alla fine romana a terra di g
saluti slayer ragazzi rigori e tanto e
sociali in description utilizzate il mio
codice creator che quello che parla di
sopra le persone perché io in editing
sono un mostro non è vero
l'ha fatto giampiero grazie a loro ma sì
io ci provo perché sono fortissimo dove
sei
eccolo non è chiarissima ma non a freddo
l'ho colpito amico sono molto amico
ciao ciao è fattibile questo sono morte
di nuovo va bene
provaci un'altra volta 6 coraggio prova
ci va bene è tranquillo ti resto io a
posto niente amico non ho più cura
scritto tutto che non ci concede non ce
l'ha non socialisti non cioè di spalla e
di spalle il sito è da mi sta guardando
a me ma cosa vuoi vai di bloccaggio
ancora lucido più o meno 1 sociali cioè
va beh ma allora fai tu ripeto molto
simpatico come sempre monito sono morto
del film the tranquilli perché ti vedevo
che è finita è finito no ma che fugge
che mi ha divorato anche le interiora
prova bene sono contento il con hard
disk ei non voglio vederlo mai più
orribile basta grazie però non può
rifarlo di libertà
no ragazzi spero che il video vi sia
piaciuto questa la da un tris vi ricordo
che potete scaricarlo in descrizione di
ingrasso pietro per aver partecipato è
utilizzato il codice creager favi gtv
per da un trash comunque per questa sì
roba anche performance volete lo trovate
sempre come must cosa non ti piace
scrivere canalis piace la campanella che
rimette sempre giuridica da ragazzi
[Musica]